hello I'm Melissa Villasenor and I'm
gonna do some of my impressions just for
fun and I hope you have fun to Britney
Spears in the house oh yeah I'm so hot
no you're not Christina Aguilera hey hey
Oh missing terrible don't think I'm Judy
Garland I'm just one of the best singers
out there somewhere over the rainbow rah
rah ah Rama Rama my Gaga oh la la want
your bad romance no one no one no one
can get it away I wanna feel in hey hey
man this is Janice Joplin man peace and
love man and no one up here is singing
the blues
you know I'm singing the blues maybe oh
if I gotta have a whole new little hand
oh your mocs on a stair hi
wait till I saw the Sun I don't know why
I didn't wear my visor you had my heart
and we'll never be worlds apart maybe in
magazines but you'll still be my star I
like to yodel yodel gonna lay you on
Anna who was my name another days gone
I'm still all alone how could this be
it's good not here with biggie
those are my singing impressions some of
them and uh here are some more celebrity
impressions okay okay okay so so here's
the deal
if there's one thing Kathy Griffin loves
it's what Oprah brings me a car filled
with my days in it yep hi I'm Sarah
Silverman and um I am I do take care of
the planet just the other day I planted
a sunflower seed in my dog's butt home
water - ah
I got you um okay so what are some other
ways that drew Barrymore can be cuter um
maybe if I meow
some more meow meow
I just need Adam Sandler to put me in
another movie that's what I really need
hello this is John Cusack I loved
playing a mom in movies I really do but
I don't like being a mom in real life
hey all hey it's Miley Cyrus hey what's
going on dad no I'm not gonna clean my
room right now want me to clean up your
bake account oh that's pretty good
that's really funny
hi I'm Zooey Deschanel um I make my eyes
bigger so I can take in more from the
world each day mm-hmm hi I'm Anna Faris
and oh oh a bird just flew right near my
head
oh man all these crazy ladies taught
them up in here man what Annabelle hmm
listen here Wallace likes me I'll shoot
all this shut the hell up man
uh-huh I'm on my with your voices man
what's up this is Ellen Page I think
acting is really cool
oh boy ell Ellen DeGeneres here uh-uh
The Ellen Show is doing well but uh I
just want to dance instead Paulo Paulo
as you'll hear let's face it American
Idol isn't doing well because they're
missing out on the real Idol and that's
me wow wow wow wow wow yeah Owen Wilson
your man yeah get outta here yeah yeah
get out why why cuz there's a fire in
the building and you're gonna die so I'm
warning you
what you can't hear me I'm speaking as
loud as I can well those are my favorite
prices to do and I hope you guys enjoyed
them stay tuned for more videos and come
to a step show sometime I'd love to have
you there bye thank you